you saw him yesterday in pennsylvania
where they you know they managed to let
him out of the basement basically so
they could cut an ad
to make it look like he's actually out
there you know it's all from the same
shot but you know joe biden was out of
his basement miraculously for a few
minutes but
he forgets where he is he forgets his
wife from his sister
he forgets the office he's running for
he's he's looking at notes you see him i
mean he literally read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff it looks like
he's trying to give an organic interview
but he's reading
the bullet points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them and now
you compare that with
okay two brain aneurysms is probably an
issue nothing to see here folks
i mean the cause and effect is so
flagrant and it
it would be sad dave if it wasn't so
scary for our country
all right people this is the reuben
report with a brand new set
and the same old host i'm back on the
grid and we're jumping right back into
the fray
joining me today is the executive vice
president of development and
acquisitions at the trump organization
and author of the new book liberal
privilege
donald trump jr welcome back to the
reuben report good to be with you dave
that is some serious branding behind you
right now i mean you guys are not
messing around man
i'll always be branding you you know the
deal i mean the last time i was on with
you
uh we both had a book coming out at the
same time so there was a little bit of
jostling uh you know for dominance there
so
uh you know this time i figured i'm by
myself so i can go all out
all right well that's exactly where
we're gonna start because we were
jostling for dominance
and uh much to the chagrin of the
fine people at the new york times at the
top of your new book
liberal privilege it says donald trump
jr
number one new york times best-selling
author
are you shocked that they allowed
your last book triggered to become not
only to make the list i mean i made the
list too
just saying but but they let you be
number one and when i say let it's
because everyone knows the whole thing
is made up
yeah you know i really was i sort of you
know one of the the dreams of last year
would have been to just be a fly on the
wall as they had to do it but
when i looked into the real you know
they tried doing the asterisk thing and
they were like
well he had some bulk sales no you know
the rnc bought like 4 000 copies of the
book now they resold them
so it's still an individual sale but
they also marked them up and resold them
they actually made a net
900 000 profit to the rnc
for themselves net right that's a big
deal so it's still an individual sales
but they said well asterisk because of
bulk sales i go but well
okay if i sold 75 000 copies in that
sort of the way they do it in that week
one right 75 000 is a huge number i was
on par with elton john the week before
so it was a big number
i said fine take that number totally out
of it and i'm at 71. i go what was
number two
and they go well this book i go how many
did they sell like 28 000. i go so
i'm 2.5 times bigger than number two
even if you take out the quote-unquote
bulk sales from it so
i don't think they had much of a choice
but they must have been really really
disappointed about that one
yeah i guess there's a little liberal
privilege involved in that
because if you were a liberal in this
case writing a book then
it would have been easier to to just put
you on the list without the sales
but basically you sold so many they
couldn't stop you so that that's
actually an interesting place to start
because
so this is your second book now within
within a year which
which ain't easy so i want to talk to
you about that but but first off
you chose to self-publish this thing and
i sense
that this is not just about you couldn't
find a publishing house i sense you're
up to something a little bigger than
that
yeah i mean we sold over 400 000 copies
of triggered you know
the last time so i actually turned down
a much better deal than my first deal
from a publisher but i'm sure you've
heard the same thing i mean a lot of
people who are writing now conservative
books
uh you know i've been with a couple of
them you know they're my friends uh some
of them have done just good books some
of them have done literal you know new
york times bestsellers
and they show me the text messages that
they get from their publishers
hey yeah we don't want you talking about
this and i'm you know these aren't guys
that are pushing like humanon nonsense
or anything like that they're not
pushing fringe
conservatism you know they're pushing
mainstream conservatism and basically
they're being threatened with part of
their livelihoods
for just taking what would be a moderate
conservative stance the publisher you
know
we're not going to publish your book if
you you know comment on this person's
article
or retweet this individual or if you
make this kind of commentary or
you're getting a little too hot so you
know honestly i had no intention of
writing another book
uh what there was the one sort of
unintended consequence of the lockdown
was
i'm at home for form i couldn't go to
work you couldn't do anything
i'm at home and i started looking at the
guy we're supposed to be running against
and you know i'm seeing the media
portray him as you know this blank slate
democrat you know
great history whatever i'm like well
let's see some details and when i
started looking i was like oh my god
someone has to write this down because
it's literally feels like it's me versus
the entire mainstream media complex i
mean
there's so much about joe biden whether
it's his just bad decisions
terrible decisions on trade terrible
decisions on race
policy stuff that's a disaster terrible
decision things that went on with his
family the graft and it's not just
hunter and the shade there but the
brother and the sister and i'm like
man if if we were joe biden with that
record this would be global news but the
media has just totally abdicated
their responsibility to look into it so
i started writing all these things
out i go you know there's a book here
someone has to put it out there someone
has to be
you know the oppo research guy that the
media you know it's sort of their job
but they're refusing to do it because
they're no longer journalists they're
just
activists they are left-wing activists
and they refuse to talk about so many of
these issues so
i started doing it and i said you know
what i don't want to be beholden to a
publisher
even if i turn down a good offer it's
like you know that doesn't matter to me
this story has to be told and i don't
want them saying yeah you know what
we're going to delay until after the
election or were you having the power to
not put it out there i just said you
know what i'm going to take a chance
and literally do it on my own it was
pretty amazing i guess on monday i was
you know number one nonfiction on amazon
but even more interestingly i made it
available on my website because you know
so many of our you know conservative
friends they don't want to give money to
big tech and stuff like that so
just on don jr.com simple like i
literally a buddy of mine found this
she's like you know that's available i
got it for almost nothing i was amazing
uh you know we're moving like about you
know 40 of the volume that i'm moving on
amazon just on this little website that
we put together because people would
rather just go direct than
give money to big tech on our side so
it's doing really well but my biggest
thing is just making sure
that message gets out there that people
you know have a chance and there's
literally 560 citations in there
pointing to all of these things so no
one can say it's fake news no one can
say no no joe biden didn't actually do
that i mean joe biden was for the wall
before he was against it
he was pro-life before he was against it
he's beholden to the radical left he
supported nafta tpp
china's permanent status on the world
trade organization that destroyed more
you know american jobs and the middle
class in the manufacturing sector
than anyone but but now magically he's
going to be the savior of the middle
class i mean
you can't make this crap up all right so
i read about half the book this morning
and
you just laid out a lot of the arguments
that you made and when i was when i was
looking at it i was thinking you know
the the alternate title basically for
this book
could have been double standards right
because that's really what you're
that's really what you're saying in this
book that if my family did these things
this is how the media would have
portrayed it if my dad had made these
decisions
this is what would have happened and if
i had gotten the the benefits that say
hunter biden had gotten
this is how the media would have dealt
it i i've said a lot of people
as as i've gotten more comfortable let's
say with your dad a lot of people will
say to me
well i don't get it dave how could you
how could you support trump how is he
how come you don't think he's the devil
all of that kind of stuff
and what i always say is well he
understood
the media more than anything else that
it wasn't just
it wasn't just republicans versus
democrats it was republicans versus
democrats
plus the media that that to me seems to
be a huge thrust of what this book is is
it
does it all boil down to the double
standards thing for you
yeah i mean yes and even and and more
right i mean because it's not just a
double standard it's
just flagrant mistakes i mean if you
just look at what's going on today
there was another fake report you know
donald trump suffered uh
many strokes you know now and he had to
be treated at walter reed now the
doctors at walter reeve said this is
nonsense it's untrue but
the media won't even talk about joe
biden who's literally had
two brain surgeries for literally
brain aneurysms he had explosions in his
brain
now if you ask a doctor about that what
are the chances that you could be a
hundred percent normal after one
you know brain surgery that you know
after an aneurysm they'd say very little
how about two almost impossible to be
normal now
you take that with joe biden's daily
daily you saw him yesterday in
pennsylvania where they you know they
managed to let him out of the basement
basically so they could cut an
ad to make it look like he's actually
out there you know it's all from the
same shot but you know joe biden was out
of his basement miraculously for a few
minutes but
he forgets where he is he forgets his
wife from his sister
he forgets the office he's running for
he's he's looking at notes you see him i
mean he literally read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff it looks like
he's trying to give an organic interview
but he's reading
the bullet points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them and now
you compare that with
okay two brain aneurysms is probably an
issue nothing to see here folks
i mean the cause and effect is so
flagrant and it
it would be sad dave if it wasn't so
scary for our country
you know joe biden is basically he's
camouflage
for the far left they can try to the
media will spend billions trying to sell
him to middle america it's moderate joe
moderate joe but you know you're not a
moderate with kamala as your vp
you're not a moderate with beto hell
yeah i'll take your ar-15 o'rourke as
your guns are you're sure it's like not
a moderate with
the bernie sanders joint unity platform
which is like a com
combination of like the new age
communist manifesto with the green new
deal blended into one
and again the media won't talk about
that so when you talk about
you know double standard it's not even
that because the playing field is so
uneven with a mainstream media that's
what 96
negative against donald trump i mean
that's a lot of ground to overcome they
won't talk about the good things you saw
well you may have been off the grid when
this happened but
they got a peace deal done in the middle
east i was just gonna bring it up yeah
this is the holy grail of geopolitical
politics hasn't been done in a quarter
of a century
they spent more time last week
fact-checking my three-year-old nephew
if in fact he did build a lego white
house for my father now there's a
picture of it
but they spend more time talking about
that because ivanka mentioned it in her
speech
attacking a three-year-old now i mean
you know nick sandman at 16 they
destroyed him i figured okay they
wouldn't go much lower than that but now
they're going to a three-year-old
to attack him but the average american
has no idea we signed a peace deal in
the middle east
and you know that's the insanity we're
up against so that's why this book it's
not just for
you know people on the right it's for
people in the middle who are undecided
because if you're undecided you're sort
of going 50 50 either way
imagine you actually knew about joe
biden and his policies imagine you
actually heard about the trump
administration's successes
neither of which you've been made aware
of that's what this boat is it's
designed to inform and again it's more
for the people in the middle that aren't
sure
than it is anything else because someone
had to step up and do it
so in the in the chapter about the biden
health stuff where you talk about the
brain aneurysms and everything else and
you refer to obama's doctor and a bunch
of other medical professionals in it
and you actually go out of your way to
make a point that you're not trying to
mock the guy and you have sympathy for
this kind of stuff like
you're not being a dick about it you're
really not um
one thing that you sort of hint at is
basically and and you sort of implied
this already
that he's just kind of a puppet for
something
what what do you really think that thing
is like
is it is it the party apparatus like who
really is in charge of the dnc at this
point
well i think it's the radical left i
mean you saw that you saw that if you
watched the dnc i don't know if you came
out of hiding yet from that one
if you didn't catch it i'm catching up
now it'll save you a lot of grief
because if you watch
that you know you'd think that america
was the most oppressive regime ever
created in the world and that it's a
terrible place and
you know again i watched for five days
not one person mentioned the looting the
writing the violence going
not one at the dnc they had a week
instead they painted this picture of you
know america's a terrible place if you
like anything about it you're a terrible
human being
and you know that's the thing i wasn't
trying to make light of dementia or
alzheimer's i mean we all know people
affected by it
the difference is those people can have
a great life they can be great parents
and grandparents and have
we're not going to give them the nuclear
football we're going to we're going to
just
pretend that didn't happen and say
congratulations here's the largest
economy in the world
here's the nuclear football i mean if
joe biden needs notes to talk to
a reporter that's literally trying to
lob him softballs
how is he going to compete against china
and russia and iran
like he can't remember where he is i
mean so you know it's
it's either insane or it's a cloak and
dagger type of thing where they you know
they
cover your eyes they pretend it's
moderate joe from scranton of which he's
not i mean he's not blue-collar joey he
got his first elected official office in
dc when he was in his 20s like he's
never had a blue collar job but
you know he's curated this sort of lie
to market himself as this way so the
radical left who's actually making all
the decisions again
his platform on his website is bernie
sanders
right you know his vp is kamala harris
who's literally left of bernie sanders
in terms of voting record in the senate
like do you think joe biden's gonna be
able to stand up to them if they're
pushing for certain things no
but the media can use him as camo you
know to sell to middle america no no
it's not gonna be that radical it's not
gonna be that bad but all you have to do
is look at this platform i mean
four trillion dollar tax hike to middle
class america to give
free health care to illegals free
education to illegals
uh free lawyers for the other ones that
will start flooding our country like
who's that gonna hurt
probably not me it's gonna hurt our
lowest income earners
right who's that gonna hurt how about
you in a public school that you have the
privilege
of having to pay for yet again right you
don't get free healthcare you don't get
free education for your kids certainly
not college or anything
but you have the privilege of paying for
illegals to get those benefits
because it creates democrat voters i
mean think about how insane that is it's
not like our systems
have all this excess capacity that they
can handle it i mean they're already
overworked
our medical system is already
overstressed our education system
honestly our public education system is
a disaster it's 28th in the world
spending more money per child than any
country in the world it's still 28th
i mean there are literally third world
countries that are beating us in
education
and the teachers union is really sure
they don't want to go back to do in
person learning
but they also don't want to do online
learning also part of their platform
since you've been gone is they want to
support blm
and defund the police what does that
have to do with educating our children
these are the radicals that we're going
to be in charge and if you just look at
joe biden you see the way he has to be
carried off the stage after he gives a
speech
or you know speech i say speech loosely
because
you know the hardest job in america is
being his sign language interpreter
because everyone no one knows what the
hell is going on
but poor guy but that's what i'm saying
it's sad
but it would be sad if it wasn't more
scary for america
yeah all right you gave me you gave me a
lot there so
sorry let's talk no no that that's good
so let's just
do the kamala thing here for a minute
because were you guys
when i say you guys the trump
organization the the campaign
your dad what was the feeling when when
it came
out that it was kamala because on one
hand i think she's probably
not as full say communist marxist
whatever that bernie thing is
but as you just pointed out her voting
record is pretty far
left and she's an authoritarian you know
she
she did that line that line that i keep
bringing up in the debate
where they asked biden you know will you
do an executive action on guns and he
said well anything i would do would have
to be constitutional
which of course is the right answer and
she looked at him and laughed in his
face
and now this is the person who is now
his vp how did you guys feel about the
choice
you know i i i listen i i sort of think
it's a great thing right because
you you know where her record is i mean
she's literally left of bernie in voting
records she doesn't care about those
sorts of things as you've said it's
uh so you know she's also so
disingenuous she's just
you know you see that she's a phony it's
just been pure ambition for her whole
life and you know that's a that's not a
terrible trait but it is when you
basically sell out all of your
principles to get there so for us
i think it's actually a great choice but
the media also agrees because the media
also wanted her to be
number one that's who they were pushing
for from moment number one now she's
terrible in the stage she's not so
warm she's you know just a terrible
candidate really
but for us i love it because everyone
believes she's the one that's going to
be in charge
uh you know it's sort of you know joe
biden picking her after she
now i got fact checked for this they
told me that i was they threw me off
instagram for this one because i said
she called him a racist and she said to
believe his sexual assault accusers
because again
remember when someone accuses joe biden
even though there's corroborating
evidence much more so
that doesn't count only those who accuse
trump of something with much with no
evidence
with no corroboration with all nonsense
you know that's to be believed but when
it happens to joe biden from a senate
staffer no no nothing to see here
but she did those things and you saw her
absolutely demolish him
on the debate stage as it related to his
racial decisions and his history there i
get into that in the book a lot
but i said well she called him a racist
and she said to believe his sexual
assault
accusers so of course that gets fact
checked well she didn't call him a race
cycle what do you mean
they go well she didn't say the words
racist i go
yeah but she went on a five-minute
diatribe about how he supported bossing
how he partied with segregationists how
he
i mean she did literally everything but
no reasonable person in the world would
assume
that she meant anything other than yeah
i think joe biden's a racist but they
can fact-check you as false
uh you know they they don't seem to
fact-check joe biden in pennsylvania
yesterday
or the day before when he says i'm not
against fracking i'm like well
here's you on that same debate stage joe
saying that you'd eliminate fossil fuels
that you said no new fracking here's you
talking to another woman saying
we're going to eliminate it all i mean
there's 50 clips of him saying exactly
the opposite but
because fracking is an important issue
in pennsylvania that is a swing state
the media will literally run with the
lie there
where it's more of a sensitive issue
they'll run with exactly the opposite
and pretend as though both of them are
true just depending on who they're
selling to
you they're not fact checking this is an
egregious lie there's tape all over the
place not one fact check called them out
on it
not one social media site took him down
for dishonesty they let him run the clip
as though it's true it's on his platform
just go look at his website so
again part of the whole thing that's
liberal privilege you can have
the best of all worlds it doesn't matter
what the truth is
it doesn't matter we are going to sell
to the american public whatever it is
that they want to hear
to be able to effectuate the change that
they want which is to put joe biden in
office or whoever his puppet masters
really are
so is the best example of that the exact
video that biden launched his campaign
with which was the charlottesville
video and he is basically saying your
dad is supporting white supremacists
when of course
and no matter how many times we talk
about this it never makes it to
mainstream media
the sentence before your dad said find
people on both sides and of course what
he meant
was of the statue debate he completely
condemned the kkk and the white
supremacists and the neo-nazis anyway
but the media ran cover for biden on
that so in biden's mind or whatever is
left of it he was just like all right
well
i can just keep running online hey why
not run with it i mean
they'll do whatever it takes to win it's
no problem right that's that's what
they're gonna do by the way they brought
that up at the dnc
multiple times as though literally
you're right the first sentence
led up to it so it was clear before it
wasn't like he made a mistake and
recovered
it was very clear to begin with they
play one portion of the clip and then
they talk they forget about the second
sentence which was
and of course i'm condemning the white
supremacists and the crazy people that
were there because it wasn't
all that but they run with it as though
it's the gospel i mean it's the same
thing in the media
they're still running dave with russia
collusion
they're still pretending like that's a
real thing notice how there no one has
any interest in like looking into comey
and the fbi and obama and
biden himself unmasking us it's the
first time we've had a non-peaceful
transition of power
a great great great american tradition
for 240-something years
nothing to see here folks now it was a
big deal for three years when they
thought it worked the other way
when it worked against trump when when
they could do that i mean you see the
testimony of these clowns
i mean under oath they say x on cnn
later that day they say exactly the
opposite because no one's going to hold
them accountable
they know it's not true because they're
literally under oath saying the opposite
but guess what we get a cnn job
how about you know the comeys and the
mccabe some these guys lied to congress
well you know it's really bad you said a
lot of congress but nothing to see i'd
be in jail if i lied to congress
they get paid big bucks to then be a cnn
contributor i mean they're rewarded
for treason they're awarded for lying to
the country and to the american people
that's sort of what we're up against and
again that's why i i took it upon myself
to do this book when i had no intention
to do it because
i've been a part of it i've you know if
you didn't believe in the deep state if
you didn't believe in sort of
these big government things prior to
2016
you know what i get it if you don't now
if you think that these people are truly
just trying to represent you and they're
not just taking care of themselves
you're out of your mind look at what my
father's trying to do you know pulling
troops out of afghanistan ending these
never-ending wars that our own generals
can't even tell us why we're there
anymore
you know they start leaking opposition
research trump is getting soft on russia
what
there's more sanctions on russia than
any than any administration in american
history
but they do that because they want to
stay in endless wars because they don't
care about sending
nice kids from middle america to go lose
life and limb abroad so they can keep
the military industrial complex going
and that's not just democrats that
they're a big part of it but it's also
the neocons
and sort of the never trump republicans
that hate that he's getting out you know
what
because they want to be on the board of
raytheon for 500 000 a year
they'll do whatever it takes they'll get
their board seat they'll do that all of
their friends get rich
sending our kids to die for something
that we don't even know why we're there
and it never ends trump tries to pull
out of these things
and you literally have people in
congress trying to literally
stop him from doing it uh and it's so
obvious
and yet again nothing to see here folks
yeah no it's like you've suddenly got
the never war
left sort of pro-war because trump's
against war
does your dad love the fact or do you
love the fact that
he has been able to make his opponent
say and believe almost anything as long
as it's in opposition to him like
like when he wakes up in the morning
that's got to be the the greatest joy of
this whole thing
is that to to get people who aren't
grounded in anything other than hating
one guy you can make them
well he can make them believe anything
or say anything
yeah it's amazing the things you know
and again you saw that you saw that with
the riots i mean
donald trump condemns variety so so they
support them
i mean they're literally the democrats
again not one person mentioned them in
the dnc
because if donald trump's again we have
to take exactly the opposite approach
finally
joe biden and it was like you know a
tepid response at best
well the riots aren't so good he only
said that after chris cuomo and don
lemon are on cnn saying oh man it's
starting to affect us in the poll
numbers
that's the problem with the democrats
you know they could solve some of these
problems but they're not interested in
solving the problems because
if you solve the problem you can't
campaign on victimhood you can't
campaign on it
so finally when it's affecting its polls
you know nothing to see here for the
first
three months of it you know they were
wonderful peaceful protests with
buildings
i guess that spontaneously combusted in
the background just total coincidence of
course dave
yeah but now it's affecting him in the
polls now we got to come out against it
i mean
what kind of leadership is that you know
he came out of the basement to do this
to get a clip to make it seem like he
hasn't been hiding in the basement the
day before that he announces well i'm
going to come out of hiding
in 10 days to address 10 days
well is is he just hiding because he's
that incompetent or is he just not
capable of coming out of the basement i
mean
obviously they'll question trump's
health at every turn but like
when he's got real issues a real history
of you know his own doctor he's not a
healthy guy i mean read the chapter in
there you'd say oh
jesus christ i mean you think this guy
is going to be there at three o'clock in
the morning when something really goes
down and you gotta
will he be with it you know or what are
they giving him something
so that he can appear even a little bit
lucid or coherent you know at times for
the few seconds that they put him on air
and the rest is a disaster is he
physically not capable
of being out more than once a week
because it sure looks like it to me but
no one's going to question it i guess i
had to yeah so you mentioned the uh the
peaceful transition of power that we've
had here for about 240 years and that
that was
really at risk just three years ago do
you think that
they basically the democrats at this
point are basically setting the stage to
not
accept the results uh no matter what and
when i say no matter what i mean i mean
with with your dad winning
yeah of course i mean you know you saw
hillary say that he should not accept it
no matter what i mean
in all fairness she hasn't accepted it
yet either
you know the democrats they talk about
all these things remember prior to 16
she said
the trumps they're not gonna they're not
gonna accept that they're not gonna
accept it turns out she didn't accept it
turns out they launched an entire hoax
for four years
that the media was 100 complicit in
pushing for them because it's their
marketing department
you know look at stacy abrams and
georgia i mean she still thinks she's
the governor of georgia
i mean the democrats have a you know
a current history of not accepting
election results uh
and pretending that it didn't happen
they're doing whatever they can to try
to you know
cheat steal you see the craziness with
some of the mail-in ballots they just
want blanket ballots i mean
there's elections that happened three
months ago that they don't even know who
won because they have no idea five
people
living in one apartment are getting the
same ballots i mean it's insane but
they'll do whatever they can to win they
don't care there's no principle there
anymore
so what what's the plan then let's go on
the assumption here that your dad wins i
i suspect that he will and i think he's
going to win probably by a much larger
margin than
than most people think but if the media
and the dems won't
accept it like what's the plan to kind
of
get us over this hump get us to a place
where even the people who you disagree
with politically
you know that everyone kind of feels a
little more in the fold is there is
there a plan do you think it's even
possible
i think i think when he wins you know
and he's not running for election again
i think things will normalize i
i do think that i think people you know
some of that hysteria
will eventually go away and they'll say
fine he's got four more years we got to
get through it
in all fairness he built the greatest
economy america's ever known he's
probably the the guy that can do it
again
you know i think some of that vitriol
ends it's not gonna end while there's an
election ongoing and we just gotta
you know we gotta make sure we have that
we you know staffing up teams and you
know
poll watchers and watching for all of
the things that are gonna be so flagrant
going on you know i mean you saw
the article that came out yesterday it's
like well trump's probably gonna win on
election day but by the time we count
you know the crates that show up you
know that that are found constantly in
the back of people's trunks oh
look oh oh how many are we down by 5001
okay
well magically i found 5002 ballots here
100 of them are democrat
amazing how this happens i mean it's
it's insane so i think that you know
people have to be watching out for that
people have to be ready for that
let's have an open and honest election
you know if you can loot in person dave
you can vote in person you know where
there's absentee systems in place in
some of these states great
you know vote that way you know we have
no problem with absentee balloting but
the conflation of sort of mailing voting
where everyone
who's ever lived at an address for the
last decade you know a magical ballot
shows up in their thing
you may not live there anymore you have
no idea to verify it
you know and everyone's just going to
turn them in and be honest and ballot
harvest
i mean no one believes that's real i
mean look at jerry nadler in new york
you know your former congressman he said
how insane this system is i mean he's on
the record saying hey it's right for
cheating look at what's going on in new
jersey look at what went on in some of
the special election stuff
you know 60 days out they don't even
know who won they're like oh we'll just
give it to someone because you know why
not
i mean it's insanity so with all of that
in mind
and election coming and all the
craziness
getting ramped up and i will tell you
this my friend after you take a month
off and you just suddenly
come back to the craziness in one day
you know particularly
crazier the day you get back then than
doing it every day
um do you think that
your dad let's say your dad wins and
do you think that we just continue with
lockdowns we continue with race riots
all of those things like because they
sort of need it
at this point like there's almost
nothing left
well you know i i think you know the
democrats are going to do what democrats
do they'll blame trump you know that
there's riots
in democrat states in democrat cities
run by democrat governors and democrat
mayors and democrat city councils in
some cases for 100 years and it's
trump's fault i mean
i don't i don't think anyone's buying
that they tried selling it just like
they tried selling it as peaceful
protest for a while people were like
it's not really oh well if it's not
peaceful protesting then it's trump's
fault i was like well
how what happened how do you how do you
make that flip but they can and
they they will do it with a straight
face the reality is you know you see the
stuff that came out of the cdc the other
day they said my father's
peddling fake news because the cdc put
out things saying that yeah you know
listen
uh six percent of the corona virus
deaths that were previously coronavirus
that only six percent of them were
actually coronavirus the arrest had to
do with
you know significant comorbidities where
a big percentage of those people may
have been dead within the year with or
without corona
and you know so i don't think we believe
in a lockdown we've seen the statistics
it doesn't work as effectively as
everyone said it was going to do
you know we tried that joe biden oh yeah
if someone says to lock down i'll just
lock down forever why not
we'll lock down forever because guess
what if your business gets destroyed
who cares you come to us government will
help you
congratulations it's like a drug dave
they're going to hook you in government
handouts forever and
honestly that's a winning strategy for
democrats and
and voting because they need you to be
dependent on the government the second
you're not the second you're independent
the second you're making money all of a
sudden their policies aren't that good
they're not that helpful so you know
they don't that's why they don't mind
the shutdowns that's why they don't mind
the constant lockdown that's why
without any science you know guys like
the blossom wow in indoor dining we're
just gonna shut it down forever like you
know we'll just another couple years why
not
you know let's wait for a vaccine well
there may be a vaccine or you know i
don't know
there's no aids vaccine yet that's been
40 years but we're going to shut down
the economy for 40 years
it's it's so what is the role of the
federal government then
i'm sure you and your dad have talked
about this i mean i know you basically
tried to let the states do their thing
and you know my feelings on this i think
that's the right thing but i also get
your point which is
a state like california which has a
progressive governor or new york
progressive governor
they in effect want to destroy
themselves
in essence to take out trump do you
think at some point
your dad is still the president of
people that live in new york and
california
does the federal government have some
responsibility then to figure out how to
how to stop
that nonsense well i you know you're no
different than the riots i mean we do
believe in states rights we do believe
in that sort of
the federalism aspect of our
constitution that's why you know when
the media runs you know trump's a
dictator i go you mean because he
offered
he offered reinforcements to police
agencies that are being overrun
but didn't mandate them to go in i'm
trying to say i i don't know how
you quite come up with this but but they
will and no matter what he does
it's bad and so you know i do believe
there is that role for the states that's
important
that's a big part of what we
fundamentally understand and agree with
that someone on the ground may know
better but i think it's more about
the people in those states recognizing
it i live in new york city i see it
people
are fed up they think de blasio's
incompetent the people where my cabin is
upstate
you know why were we shut down there
were two cases in the entire county
we were shut down for three months we
destroyed our business we lost you know
the summer revenue that we'd get
yeah people are sick of it and i so i
think it'll be a little bit of a
self-regulating process because you know
these politicians all have future
aspirations you know and while cuomo's
been heralded as the savior of america
you know by any medical metric he's 50
out of 50.
you know 50 out of 50 states but you
know he's the hero a guy like ron
desantis with a larger state
a more elderly and therefore susceptible
population
has one tenth the deaths and he can't do
anything right according to the media
it's
it's insane uh it's mind-blowing but
again
i i think they've overreached the
liberal privilege has become so flagrant
that real people actually see through it
you know if they're a little biased as
they've been for decades fine you give
them
okay fine maybe we discounted a little
bit but now you turn on the tv like
yeah what i'm seeing is not true what
i'm seeing is not true and people get it
do you miss the the good liberals
because uh we talked about this last
time but you're a new yorker you grew up
mostly around liberals uh i know you
have a lot of friends that are still
liberals like do you miss that that new
york liberal that was not sort of the
banana's lefty
i i do and it's sort of interesting i
mean some of them are still that way and
honestly some of them are just like i
can't believe what's going on i'm like
you know the same guys that you don't
have for years i mean obviously i'm such
a big you know gun guy right so the same
guys that for years told me
why do you need an ar-15 there's no
background check
it's ridiculous you know don what ar-15
should i buy um
john oh my god there's a waiting period
what's going on i want a gun there's
stuff going on in my neighborhood i mean
i go
for 10 years you told me that these
things didn't exist because you had no
idea but that was the talking point
you know i think they're waking up to
how ridiculous it's become so
you know it's been a little bit
cathartic for me because you know those
radicals that you know just you
literally
you know i used to be able to put myself
in their shoes argue their point it's
not like i
stick to 100 conservative dogma you know
that in the conversations we've had
way before we even got into politics i'm
pretty open about that and yet
you know i used to be able to argue
those points i can't argue the
mainstream democrat platform anymore
with a straight face and be like this is
this is somehow good for america
most of them can't and and that's the
problem they see it so
there's plenty of you know those
democrats i know a bunch they're just
like
yeah you know we don't love every aspect
of what you're doing but like we believe
economy we believe in freedom we believe
in freedom of speech we believe it
and you're listing these things that you
know i said in my convention speech like
you know freedom of speech and thought
that used to be a liberal value
you know try wearing your tolerance used
to be a liberal value i mean they still
run around they're the party of
tolerance i'm saying
try wearing a maga hat in portland you
know try wearing a manga in one of these
major cities now if you wore
a biden hat and i haven't seen any of
them but if someone
made one and there's got to be one
somewhere yeah
wear it in the most you know i don't
want to call it maga country that's a
jesse smellette special but like
uh you know in in the most conservative
no one's gonna they won't even say
anything to you they won't
they won't spit at you they won't they
won't beat you over the head with a
brick like you're seeing in these videos
you know they won't loot your store
cancel your business or
you'll get petitions going to to ruin
your life on facebook they won't do that
but try doing it the other way so you
know the party of tolerance isn't so
tolerant and i think a lot of reasonable
democrats
you know uh get that i also think a lot
of sort of that that history that
blue-collar working-class union democrat
that had a tradition of voting that way
i think they get it too
they're saying what is you know i used
to hear it in 16 well you know don if my
grandfather knew that i was voting for a
republican
he'd be rolling over in his grave i go
well what would he say about today's
democrat platform not that one
and he goes huh you know you're right
don like oh my god
i go how many genders are there 96 or
two what would he say
you know john f kennedy you know this
pillar of the democrat party he'd be all
right today dave he'd be cancelled
right he'd be me tooed and canceled and
it would be over i mean
uh it's just not your grandfather's
democrat party anymore and i think
that has ostracized you know so many
former democrats where they're starting
to become you know
either somewhat conservative uh moderate
or or really you know sort of
libertarian in many of their views which
are so many of my views too
yeah i i hear you man and we've had many
discussions about it let's let's jump to
a private discussion we had about it
because i think it'll it'll get to
something really interesting here
which is uh my audience has heard it but
one night
uh you you and kimberly invited david
and i
to dinner at mar-a-lago we had a really
nice dinner we we argued about politics
for
two three hours uh i had a couple drinks
you do not drink so i'm not sure who won
the arguments
but we did about three hours there and
then at the end your dad was there and
by the way this was right at the
beginning of impeachment and everybody
said the walls are closing in he's
freaking out
the guy's sitting there he has no tie on
he was with giuliani and some people and
he's laughing and having fun
anyway at the end of dinner he said hey
would you like to meet my dad and i was
like uh yeah i'd like to
meet the president let's do it and you
introduce us and then
he turns to david and he says well who
are you and david says well
i'm his husband and your dad immediately
like there was no pause he
clapped his hands together he slapped
him on the table he said that's great
that's just great
i want to stand up and shake your hands
he shakes our hands he says the only
thing wrong with you guys is you're too
handsome melania can you believe it
these handsome guys are married and it
was just so
obvious to me that in this completely
unscripted
unplanned moment where you just brought
us up to him that he
he actually said i don't know if he
wants me saying it but i've said it
before
he said i want you guys to know
something i don't give a [ __ ]
and i don't think anyone's giving a [ __ ]
in in 20 years talking about about gay
marriage or whatever
um how do you get over
the labels when it comes to something
like that just the base stuff your dad
is
or your family is homophobic or they're
racist
because no matter how many times i tell
that story people say i'm a sellout
somehow or
something you know some version of some
of that stuff now well
the reality is this donald trump is the
first person to run for president of the
united states
that when he ran he was for gay marriage
i mean obama was against it because he
was told he had to be against it and
maybe he wasn't in his actual
convictions but as part of his platform
he was against it
because that's what they had to do right
that you listen to the talking points
and you must succumb to them
so you know again donald trump's been
way ahead of that curve i think we have
we're from new york i mean it's like a
pretty big percentage of the people
around us at any given time are probably
we just don't care what you do in your
own you know who gives a [ __ ] no one
no one's gonna care it's one of those
issues you're right i mean we're already
there frankly but in 20 years it'll be
even
even different or even more so i mean
even some of the older school people
that you know
maybe a little bit more you know just
kind of read the
sort of the older religious dogma on it
like no one cares
even the people that say they care they
don't care they sort of they feel
obligated to do it donald trump just had
the guts to be like hey i don't care i'm
running for the republican you know
nomination and this is not an issue for
me whatsoever go have at it
i always joke you know the best wedding
i ever went to was a gay wedding because
it was on a tuesday
they were like yeah we don't want to
screw up your weekend we're just going
to have fun on a tuesday i think that's
perfect this is the greatest wedding
ever i don't have to lose my whole
weekend that's awesome i love you guys
um and so you know he hasn't but again
you see it every day
donald trump has been so proud i think
you guys didn't have a problem with
obama literally running against gay
marriage
in 2008 but donald trump runs
as a conservative you're literally going
against
the you know the more traditional dog
might again i don't think it's a party
platform issue at this point
like i said i don't think anyone cares
they probably have it for a while but he
literally said i don't care
well you know guess what you know you're
a republican you're trying to get the
evangelical vote and you still say hey i
don't care about that
but people live and let live i mean the
republican party is the true party of
tolerance
now that doesn't mean you know you know
i've been open about this too and it
doesn't mean i don't draw the line some
places again i don't care how you even
identify
where i start to care is when you know
you're 6'2
285 and jack and you decide you want to
be a woman and compete against you know
my daughter in sports
you know i i don't identify how you want
but you start taking her scholarship
i have a problem i wonder where the
people who fought for title ix are
how come they won't say anything but
it's interesting when i've come out on
some of those things and again i don't
give a crap if you're trans or not that
makes no difference to me it's when
you sort of let's let's have the best
let's take a female athlete who's
top of her game who's worked her whole
life i'm a journeyman male athlete it's
not working out so well congratulations
i'm going to flip and now i'm a state
champion i'm getting your scholarship
i have a problem with that and i've said
it i've been very vocal about it i've
even put it out on twitter
and it's interesting because if i put
out anything on twitter you know
before someone could have even read you
know read my tweet
they're up there with the hate mail and
the hate commentary but when i do that
one
it's sort of interesting i get this note
like damn it
ah man god damn it i hate him but i'm
with don jr on this one
you know but the democrat party doesn't
have the sense to stand up and say
enough is enough identify how you want
but let's like
let's not start destroying opportunities
for females and like i said where where
are all the feminists
you know on this issue i mean basically
this should be their biggest issue yeah
but they won't so that's why
it's important for trump to be able to
acknowledge these things to be able to
combat it to not just blindly follow the
dogma
but with the left today you know you
have to be woke
and if you're not woke enough that by
itself is now cancelable dave you
you get canceled for not being woke but
again it's not like the goal posts are
fixed
the goal post move ever and ever like
you could wake up one day you were woke
yesterday by today you're all right
you haven't kept up with the latest bat
[ __ ] crazy concept
you know that they're jamming down your
throats as a narrative and if you don't
get there
you're out you know you might as well be
full-fledged conservative even if you're
99
liberal do you see a reason for that i
mean i've been saying for a while now
that the fundamental reason for that is
that
basically if you're on the right if
you're a conservative
that you believe in individual rights
that's the number one thing you believe
that everyone should be treated equally
under the law it doesn't mean you act
like it all the time but that's
sort of the fundamental principle i
can't figure out what the fundamental
principle is of the left anymore other
than government
and that is an ever-moving goal post
it is and i can't either like i said i
literally can't keep up by the time we
get done
with this talk i can look on my twitter
feed and be like wow like new outrage
cycle probably three or four of them
like things that at any other point in
time in history wouldn't be
even remotely outrageous let alone
contentious
uh but it's like it's a race who can
outvoke themselves
to the point where it's become a parody
i mean it's a shame because it doesn't
mean there's not issues in the world
that we don't have to address but when
you scream panic when you're screaming
fire in a crowded theater every time
there's something and everyone mobilizes
immediately where's the problem
you you desensitize people to real
issues i mean racism one of those things
i call it sort of
the easy button over the left you know
if i can't win an argument if i don't
have thanks to back me up if i don't
have statistics racist
obviously i mean what are you doing what
does your dad do
what does your dad do to combat the fact
that
it works it doesn't matter if he's on
stage during the state of the union
saying black unemployment
all-time low and the congressional black
caucus sits there like this i thought
they would maybe applaud that or be
happy about that
but what do you do to just combat the
horrific way that that nonsense
sticks i think honestly you just got to
keep fighting it you got to keep winning
you know
i don't i don't think there's a chance
that in in any time soon you know the
media is going to become
unbiased i don't think you do that i
think you have to just keep winning
you have to put up the numbers you have
to make sure that a reasonable amount
of the people see that and i think they
do i think if you look at you know our
numbers within the you know
african-american community right now and
they
they get it they see what's going they
don't want violence in their streets
you know they're watching the media you
know as their businesses are burning
down you know many of these businesses
are minority owned they're burning down
and
no one's looking to help them they're
looking to get them you know a picture
of it as though this is somehow trump's
fault but
i think they see through it you know
it's it's harder to get through
you know those levels especially in the
big and inner cities you know
because there's such a stranglehold by
the democrat party within those cities
that to get the information to
disseminate down
you know to the voter uh is hard you
gotta you're going through so many
levels of filters but i always say like
you know if joe biden knew how to fix
racial issues
you know why didn't he do it by now i
mean he had 50 years he was vice
president for eight years under obama
the first african-american president
like
if you really wanted to fix it you could
have focused on opportunity zones
you could have even tried they had the
house and the senate they didn't even
attempt it
because they need you to be a victim
they need to be able to come back to you
every four years you're a victim
so well why didn't you fix it in your
half a century joe
you know is anyone dumb enough to
believe that he's gonna somehow fix it
now
yeah well speaking of fixing stuff
people kind of forget because you're
thought of
now as as a political guy although that
really is
not what you what you truly are at least
at the day-to-day level
um you you're running trump properties
and trump hotels and all that stuff
we spoke a little bit right at the
beginning of of the lockdown
and you you were freaking out about what
was happening to the economy and
employees that you had had i think you
told me there was there was a guy that
you had
for like 35 years that you were gonna
have to temporarily furlough or
something like a whole bunch of stuff
where are you guys at business-wise
right now
what's going on with just hotel business
and the other stuff that you
care about and spend most of your day
talking about yeah listen
that's not easy the hotel business you
know people aren't traveling cities are
locked down you can't have dining you
got to wear masks i mean you know it's
not a great time to be in the hotel
business now
you know for better or worse unlike
hunter biden we used to be international
business people too
uh we stopped doing new international
deals you know when my father took
office to avoid even the notion of
impropriety
now hunter biden became an international
business miraculously
became an international businessman when
his father took the vp so we're doing
the best we can with some of our you
know the clubs and stuff like that
people are actually good they want to
get outside their
golf clubs are doing well hotels is a
rough business right now but we got to
fight through that and we got to build
back the economy but i think that's
what's important about trump
he's the guy that did it once before
he's the guy that despite like probably
more incoming fire than any president in
modern history
built the greatest economy we've ever
known created the lowest employment
numbers cut the red tape and the
bureaucracy cut taxes so that businesses
could employ more people
wages were going up for the lowest
income earners like he's the guy that
can do it again coming out of this
crisis
coming out of a global pandemic caused
by china no joe biden when donald trump
shut down travel from china joe biden
called him a racist
i mean at what point in history dave
would shutting down
travel from the epicenter of a deadly
viral outbreak be anything other than
common sense
was it racist when we did it from europe
too no but that allowed us to slow down
the spread it allowed us to create you
know
ventilators public private partnerships
to do that get the ppd in the hospitals
i mean it's a virus it's not like you
can stop it but
their scree they would have left the
country open for a month overwhelmed our
systems
you know but again that liberal
privilege allows you to basically not
have a solution say that trump did it
all wrong despite the facts despite
the positions that they were taking at
the time and it's like a big win and the
media cheers them on as though he did
something
competent and they they clearly won't
talk about joe biden in the obama
administration's response to
swine flu in 2009 luckily that wasn't as
deadly as this
thank god but literally tens of
thousands of people had it before they
did anything
then they didn't replenish their stocks
joe biden had a similar role to mike
pence
uh you know back in 2009 on this and his
own guy his guy
said man we got lucky this thing wasn't
deadly because we literally did
everything wrong it's in the book i mean
i do a chapter on that one because
conveniently because it was the obama
administration they were infallible they
could do nothing wrong even when
they had glaring errors so people won't
hear that they need to see the corollary
before they're sold
this notion that joe biden would have
somehow done it so much better because
they had their chance they blew that too
all right well we've done about 49
minutes according to that clock right
there and we haven't talked about big
tech and i would say
maybe more than anybody you're in the
center of the big tech fight
um as most of my audience knows uh you
now have a community on locals which is
the tech company i started and you own
it you control it you can do whatever
you want with it and every time you get
booted off twitter you can put your put
your stuff on local so you're safe and
your audience can find you
but do you think that perhaps the
biggest liberal
privilege that exists is the privilege
to be able to say what you want on big
tech platforms and not be suspended
while a guy like you or plenty of other
just right-leaning people we're not
talking about
alt-right racists and we're not talking
about people that are threatening to
murder people
uh are are gonna get the booth a hundred
percent i mean
you know i've been vocal about this for
years and you know i've been thrown off
every platform
imaginable again not for pushing
anything crazy but for pushing basic
you know conservative thought uh you
know you talk about the alt-right i'm
not defending them in any way shape or
form but
there's an alt left there's a there's a
super radical left a hate-filled
organization
whether it's hezbollah whether it's the
ayatollah talking i mean just yesterday
anti-semitic tropes
well that doesn't violate community
guidelines twitter a few weeks ago
china putting out disinformation
i mean they acknowledge these are
chinese government officials
disseminating
coronavirus disinformation on twitter
does not violate their community
standards
but me putting up a tweet about a couple
doctors treating patients
with hydroxychloroquine in the field
medical doctors
doing it seeing real results i say wow
this is great i didn't even say hey this
is fact
i said interesting because it's very
different than the narrative we've been
spoon-fed i got thrown off twitter
yeah that was that was the one that
booted you off twitter right before i
left yeah
yeah you know i got i got in trouble
with instagram back in the day when i
called out jesse smallett
and i just said i don't know like if
this happened in america
you know fry those bastards that [ __ ]
does not fly here
uh but has anyone like you know looked
into the story because you know i see
ellen and every today show and oh my god
it was their dream come true you know
white supremacists wearing manga hats in
chicago like i go
you think they would have lasted more
than 10 or 12 seconds without getting
shot like
do you think like these guys knew who
jesse smallett is because i don't know i
i don't know many white supremacists i
don't think i know any and i wouldn't
associate with them if i knew they were
but i have a feeling they're not
watching empire
i mean you know i just don't think you
know i don't think it's a show for them
like if you're a white supremacist
you're probably not watching empire
you probably don't assume that this
really rich actor is going to go get
subway at 2 a.m on the coldest night of
the year
you know i've been all over and then
leave the news he left
the little shoestring news it was like
twine i'm like i don't know
you know if the guy's a decent actor
maybe i haven't seen the show but like
he's not a good writer but i was the
only person in america
with you know like let's call it with a
following with something to lose that
was like okay
screw this like i'm all in because this
has to be [ __ ] now if i was wrong
i'm over right it can't
i'm canceled forever um but i mean i i
got
donald trump jr spreading hate he's an
anti this he's not a terrible human
being well it turns out i was right
uh turns out i was right uh you know no
one questioned it because it was so good
they had to push it so
you know to get thrown off platforms you
the most vile people on the left
well whether that's pornographic whether
that's this whether it's you know
anti-semitic not one has ever been
thrown off twitter not one has ever
taken their content down not one gets
fact checked
like joe biden and the pennsylvania
stuff even the
it's one-sided you've never heard of one
of those instances deep platforming
demonetization
and so it's a real threat they are
heavily putting
uh their foot on the scale of this
election it's literally like i said
earlier
it's why i made my book available on
junior.com
rather than just on amazon or you know
any of the other platforms you can get
them there if you want the one-click
shopping but like a lot of our guys were
like
i just don't want to give it to amazon i
just don't want to do it i was like okay
here's another option for you
and like i said i'm moving like a really
big amount of volume just on my own
little website
because they don't want to go to amazon
because they see
you know what's going on with big tech
now amazon i don't think they've done
anything with me on that one it's you
know the
twitter facebook instagram you know they
play much more games
uh i don't know that they're playing
games with me on amazon i didn't notice
it the last time around
but people don't want to support that
and we need to create an environment
people have said you know well start
conservative twitter i was like i don't
really want to do that either because i
actually want to have the argument
may the best idea win i mean that's a
concept that goes
deep in american history um they don't
even want to hear the corollary they're
going to spoon feed you a narrative that
is the narrative that is it you cannot
question it you're not allowed to touch
it if you do
uh you're canceled and you're over uh
that's really scary for the future of
our country and for the next generation
so what do you want to happen with big
tech i mean we see
you know every few months we trot out
zuckerberg and we trot out you know jack
from twitter and and the rest of them
and they
they you know say what either may or may
not be true
or get caught in half-lives or
everything else um and then you know
your dad did roll back some of their
protections with section 230
of the communications act but what what
do you actually think
is the right thing and and do you think
it's kind of too late relative to an
election that's going to happen in about
two months
it will be for this election you know
they've been putting their foot on the
scale for the last four years they've
been pushing the russia this information
you know
in boxing is a big issue you know
because that's not just social media
right that's you know
information you know if you sign up for
five democrat congress people that are
running for congress right now and sign
up for five republicans
check your junk mail which which ones
are going to your junk mail and which
ones are ending up at the top of your
inbox i mean google and all those places
they're doing that kind of stuff too
they're really you know putting it on
there but the big problem that we've
always faced and you and i know we've
had this conversation is that
a lot of conservatives don't even
understand the issue you know you had an
old
you know conservative senator he's got
25 year old running his social media has
no idea he doesn't see it you know when
i hit send i know what it's going to do
until the algorithm kicks in and screws
with me you know i know within a couple
of
likes how many retweet that one's going
to get versus this one up like i'll send
this one it's not great but it'll do
okay this one's going to go big
i know and i've seen it you know 2 000 3
000 4 000 stop
it's over you know the algorithm catches
it and censors it
the problem is for so long so many
republicans don't even realize that it's
an issue
they don't realize it's a top issue with
their base who just want that freedom of
speech you know if you're pro-life if
you're
a second amendment if you're religious i
mean your accounts get scrutinized
you know screwed with much more than
anything else
and so a big part of what i've tried to
do is wake up conservatives they do this
whole
well it's free market no it's not it's
not free market when
you're getting billions of dollars in
liability protections from the federal
government and you're acting as a
publisher deciding
who's going to magically show up in a
google search i mean look at breitbart
you can't even find breitbart on google
it will not but if you issue do
something you know buzzfeed
all the left-wing rags you know they'll
show up as though that is the gospel
you can't you don't even have that
access to the information unless you
literally know the url that you're
looking to find
and so you know that affects it so we
got to stop going with this notion that
it's free market we have to wake up
conservatives to understand what's
actually going on
uh a bunch more guys are doing that i
mean you know
josh hawley's done a pretty good job in
the senate with that kevin mccarthy in
the house
but we got to get everyone else on board
and push for it because there is a point
where
you know they're going to have more
power uh than anyone in government
uh in terms of the ability to shape
hearts and minds uh
with misinformation or otherwise and
they're already doing it
yeah all right junior i got one more for
you
do well no i'm going to ask it in a
different way i was going to say do you
think your dad's going to win the
election i'm not going to say that i
know you think that
um play out the rest of the year for me
just play out what you think the next
two months will be like
election day and then what happens in
january
well listen you know next couple months
will be brutal you know we're going to
work joe's going to go from his basement
and the media is going to pretend that
he's doing something
uh you know i think we'll be able to you
know paint that picture for the american
public like the the rnc did
you know without those incredible images
and stories uh versus
you know the dnc i think we'll continue
to do that i think you see that
you know the the democrats are just
staffing up legal teams i mean
they haven't bothered to try to create a
ground game because they know there's no
enthusiasm so what they're doing is
stepping up legal teams to try to game
it out later on
uh so i see that being the case which is
why so many people have to mobilize get
your friends out make sure they vote
you know don't sit on the sidelines
because we i honestly in my opinion we
have to
win overwhelmingly um you know to get
over that hump
uh of the games that will be played on
the other side and i think if we do that
uh you know a lot of that fire goes away
because once they're sort of stuck with
trump for another four years
you know they'll deal with it they'll
move on they'll start their battle for
2024 on about november 4th covet will
magically
uh not be the talking point that it has
been because you know once
once it's over you don't need that fear
over people anymore we can get back to
leaving living our lives a little bit
more normal
doesn't mean we won't still have to deal
with it a little bit but i i imagine
it's going to be very different
uh and you'll give donald trump another
four years to build back uh that economy
and then some focus on things that he's
a builder first and foremost you said
that earlier i mean
let's do some infrastructure for america
rather than building roads tunnels and
bridges
in afghanistan that blow up the next day
let's do that here let's bring our
troops home let's put them to work here
let's create infrastructure for america
put americans back to work
i mean that would be donald trump's
wheelhouse and i think you know once you
get through an election cycle you'll see
democrats and the nancy pelosi's of the
world
you know may be finally willing to
actually try to help
rather than try to be a hindrance at
every step of the way because once
they're stuck with him for the last
thing he's not up for reelection anymore
uh you know hopefully you you infuse
some normalcy
uh back into political discourse i
didn't know you're a dreamer
i can't believe it hey everyone's gotta
have hopes
all right the book is liberal privilege
by
new york times best-selling author don
jr
don thanks for doing the show if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell